life will eventually force you to change
when you have kids I remember a lot of
times we'll be like yeah there's no way
in the world I can get away with I need
I'm I know my health Vinnie I need at
least nine hours of sleep yeah because I
know my body really go have a kid go
ahead bro go have a kid yeah go have a
kid and see what you'll realize how how
many you guys are listening to this
folks if you're listening to this you
got kids how many of you have gone to
work be honest how many you have gone to
work on 2 hours of sleep how many of you
how many of you have gone to work work
with no sleep your kid has got snot all
over your face you're sick as a dog you
don't have a choice you don't have
somebody to take care of you everybody
in the house is sick you still got to
get to work to make the money to pay
your bills and you still have to take
care of your kids and you didn't get any
sleep you know what the body tells you
you're capable of more but that's
because of force M your kids are not
forcing you to change life is forcing
you to change